hi there steve kaufman here uh just a  short video here to uh  remind those of you who don't yet know  about it that we have our link academy  live taking place for the next three  months we have three students one from  korea one from taiwan and one from  hungary  they are interacting with our link staff  here  i don't know all of the details and in  fact these will unfold  gradually  but we will be regularly posting videos  about these three  students colleagues call them  as they interact with us  and together we find better ways of  learning english  we talk about how to use link and how to  get the most out of link  we will be producing videos regularly so  you may find this interesting and i will  leave a link  to  the uh youtube channel where these  activities are being recorded so  just to let you know and uh  please stay tuned bye for now  you